this is the 2019 world Scout Jamboree
the event hosted thousands of young
people from around the world at a scout
camp in West Virginia and was sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America but Scouts
were meeting during a time of crisis for
the organization total membership for
the century-old Boy Scouts of America
was on the decline in one of its largest
sponsors the Mormon Church had announced
it would cut ties with the organization
now a slew of lawsuits alleging child
sexual abuse from decades ago has forced
the Boy Scouts to file for bankruptcy
here's how the largest youth
organization in the country filed for
bankruptcy
so the scouts were founded in 1910 and
they were based on scouting programs
were already underway and UK they really
focused on civic engagement they did
this do a lot of outdoor programs and
educational programs really focused on
raising young men to be upright citizens
as the organization grew so did the
programs and opportunities the Boy
Scouts offered in 1967 about 6 million
boys were enrolled in Boy Scouts the Boy
Scouts essentially became this pillar of
American Society and they formed a lot
of relationships with business groups
with civic groups a number of well-known
American citizens joined including Neil
Armstrong businessmen like Sam Walton
founder of Walmart Bill Gates founder of
Microsoft they really became this group
that drew a lot of men that would go on
to do big things in the worlds of
politics and business while girls have
been accepted into some scouting
programs as early as 1969 the Boy Scouts
prohibited girls in openly gay boys from
joining the Maine scouting program so
when we get to the start of the 21st
century we started to have a lot of
these membership controversies with the
scouts they wanted to be able to dictate
who would be able to come into the
scouts and who would be able to be able
to call themselves a scout the group
successfully defended its prohibition on
gay members before the US Supreme Court
in 2000
membership started to decline as boys
began to look elsewhere for
extracurricular activities you have more
sporting activities you also have
parents that were more busy there was
really much more competition for the Boy
Scouts to try and get folks to get
involved the Boy Scouts leadership voted
to allow gay youth to become Scouts in
2013 and to allow gay adults to serve as
volunteers in 2015 the group voted to
allow transgender boys then to allow
girls in 2017 despite opening its
membership to more kids the Boy Scouts
took a major hit at the end of 2019 when
the Mormon Church cut ties with the
organization effectively withdrawing 400
thousand boys from scouting when the LDS
Church announced that they were gonna be
ending their partnership with the Boy
Scouts they didn't explicitly say that
the changes the scouts were making was
the reason why but there there was some
tension there there has been a bit of a
backlash from some conservative groups
and there's been some new scouting
programs that have been started up since
that has happened but for the Boy Scouts
a disastrous problem was beginning to
bubble to the surface beginning in 2019
more than a dozen states passed
legislation that extended the statute of
limitations for child sexual abuse as a
result multiple claims were filed across
the country alleging former scouts were
sexually assaulted by Scout masters and
other volunteers mostly in the 1960s and
70s between 2017 and 2019 the Boy Scouts
of America spent more than a hundred and
fifty million dollars on settlements
related to child sexual abuse the
potential liability from other lawsuits
forced the organization to declare
bankruptcy in February 2020 their sex
abuse claims the vast majority of them
occurred more than 30 years ago and the
Boy Scouts have said that they put new
child safety programs in place make sure
kids are safe but still it's going to be
tough for them to recruit at a time when
their membership numbers are going down
so there's still a lot of uncertainty
for the Boy Scouts on the horizon you
have these declining membership numbers
you have this Bank
see that's been looming and you've had
this recent split with the LDS Church so
it's really unclear what the future of
the Boy Scouts holds